i've heard from a number of people out
on the street or even people at work at
this other show that i do or on the
weekends i was at disneyland this past
weekend you went to disneyland i went to
disneyland okay yes with some with some
friends and it was amazing and there
were so many people there obviously it
was disneyland and i heard over and over
and over again loving the podcast
loving the podcast good okay and i
always ask people what it is that they
like about it just because i'm
interested yeah
and yeah 90 of the people say that they
listen to it on the way to work yeah i
hear more listeners than
uh then i hear creeps but i know you're
out there because we see the numbers
you're watching
um people listen to us on their way to
work and they're on their way home from
work and it feels like they're hanging
out with their friends they're hanging
out with their buds yeah and i like that
because i feel like i'm hanging out with
my friends by the way somebody at
disneyland called across the like a sea
of people and goes hey mac i'm a creep
i was like all right man you're right
own it own that [ __ ]